donc la révision des conditions pour
l'état d'urgence n'est pas utile la
déchéance de nationalité est une très
mauvaise mesure
c'est en plus l'exemple même du symbole
pour rien et nicolas sarkozy qui a
beaucoup soutenu cette mesure en disant
il faut des symboles a eu tort aussi
parce que un symbole qui n'ont breil sur
aucune réalité concrète
un symbole qu il embraye sur aucun
progrès tangibles dans la lutte contre
le terrorisme et c'est le cas de cette
mesure qu'elle a comme la déchéance de
nationalité
alors le symbole un moment s'effondre
sur lui même donc cédé 6,2 posant
hollande et nicolas sarkozy sur vos
ensemble oui parce que cette mesure a
été porté par ceux qui ont voulu faire
de la com com françois hollande sur un
sujet aussi considérables dommages réels
et ceux qui n'ont pas osé dire la vérité
ce qu'ils ont considéré que dès lors
qu'ils avaient un mot viril vigoureux
fort en apparence il fallait embrayé
parce que faut suivre le mouvement
et ben non la politique de temps en
temps ça suppose de l'honnêteté se
suppose de la lucidité ça suppose du
courage et de la pédagogie
françois hollande a été dans la com
nicolas sarkozy avait embrayé à ce
moment là j'ai fait partie des quelques
uns nous le courage de dire la vérité
dès le début